I want to jump to the story because uh
my friends Elon Musk is in desperate
need for of our help of our help because
the media is lying about him and I'm
only half kidding actually I tweeted
Jack Sweeney was not posting public
information Jack Sweeney was posting the
private information of Elon Musk and he
knew Sweeney is the guy who ran the Elon
jet account Elon Musk suspended him and
all the journalists who linked to his
private data
Elon had what's called a Pia it's a
privacy icao address that is his
aircraft address was private and rotated
every month I want to show you this
archives I linked The Source Jack
Sweeney January 26 2022 he said Elon got
Pia but I've already identified it
confirmed on paa but I'm all good here
still he even said that Pia does make it
harder but he can write code to figure
it out this is not publicly available
information this was a guy who used code
and Bots to algorithmically crack the
identity of elon's plane so that he
could publish that information and Elon
made one mistake he tolerated it he was
because he wanted to be a free speech
guy he says I'm diving I'm not even
going to ban that that account
well he should have instantly yeah so
some people are saying well Elon got rid
of his Pia recently and I'm like look
if Elon was spending money for a private
rotating address to avoid being doxed
and it wasn't working he was still
getting doxed I'm not surprised that he
would eventually say what's the point of
paying for this or doing it but this is
what the journalists are lying about The
Intercept issued a statement saying our
journalist was late was was suspended
for for sharing public information but
it's not public information
so the funny thing is I can Google
anyone's address I'll find it I'll find
your name phone number address in 10
seconds it's public information you
still can't share it on Twitter all of a
sudden they're defending this and
they're lying about it here's the crazy
thing back in January one person
responded is there a way to take his
concerns about his own safety seriously
but still do this it's really cool to
have this but I don't know it just feels
odd you're a heck of a coder too
one person said please stop already
unfollowed other people cheered him on
some said why are you doing this but the
fact that you had people responding to
him being like yo this is dangerous
and he didn't care
yo this this is what evil looks like
someone who knows what he's doing is
wrong cracking someone's privacy address
and then when he was when this was
addressed because Elon so I tweeted
about this actually Elon responded to my
tweet just saying correct I don't know
if we have it right here he said correct
Jack Sweeney responded by saying Elon is
trying to say what I'm posting isn't
public information adsb and a cars are
all over public frequency and are
acquired by organizations blah blah blah
blah blah it's like saying am and FM
signals aren't public you see how he
avoided addressing the fact that he by
he cracked the Pia number yeah he's he's
because he knows what he did was wrong
in fact Elon even insinuated that what
he did was illegal that by compiling
public data to expose the Privacy
address of elon's plane and then sharing
it publicly that he actually was
committing some kind of crime I don't
know if that's the case but here's what
he wrote he said yeah so the Pia icao
can be changed monthly if chosen to do
so but even then it's relatively easy to
identify I'm confident I can write
software to identify it actually that
was in February and Elon tolerated it
and because he did as soon as he
realized just how dangerous it was and
finally said enough they tried calling
him out oh but you said before you
wouldn't do it well my attitude is that
was Elon being nice yeah now he's nuking
you yeah I mean it's it's really
infuriating
um to to hear you talk about this
because I hadn't you know I was
traveling today so I hadn't heard this
the rest of the story because just on my
show we were talking about this and we
made a comment that it was odd that he
mentioned when he first announced that
Elon jet was banned he mentioned that he
had some legal you know he's like I'm
already pursuing legal ramifications and
I thought to myself well hold on what
does he have he must know something else
because how how does he think he has a
case if this guy wasn't doing something
illegal if it's publicly available
information you have no case right so
but it's infuriating because I love you
know I'm looking at all of these places
who are supposed to be journalists
trying to find out more information no
I'm finding out from from alternative
media right that's where you find it out
you don't find it out from any
mainstream media Source Elon Musk also
responded to Ariana Jacob who tweeted
I'm not famous and I wasn't a public
figure either when Taylor Lorenz asked
for my address said it wasn't for
publication and then proceeded to dox me
in the New York Times with the address
she had assured me wasn't going to be
published the article was shared many
times on Twitter and this is uh Elon
responding saying such shameful Behavior
will not be tolerated going forward
last night there was a a big space that
Elon went into a Twitter space these
chat rooms right had like a hundred
thousand or some ridiculous amount of
people and it was a bunch of woke
journalists and left-wing activists and
Elon came in and said journalists you're
not special if you docs you'll be banned
thank you goodbye and then the crazy
thing about it was that several
suspended accounts were able to actually
be in the space it's fascinating to
listen to these people who knew nothing
about what they were talking about they
were saying things like tracking planes
is publicly available information
incorrect they said you know if you're
on a plane anyone can post the tail
number and whatever it's like yeah but
if you're flying commercial no one knows
who's on the plane elon's plane is
elon's plan it's him or his family
so they didn't they didn't quite
understand understand this and the most
important element for people to
understand private airport terminals
typically have no security you can
literally just jump a four foot fence
and be on the tarmac at one of these
airports these are small Regional
airports often sometimes they're on the
back of a major airport and they'll have
some like maybe an eight foot fence but
that's it it's a chain link fence you
you in in uh let me let me teeterboro
teeterboro is is the New York area
airport where most people try to fly
into because JFK and LaGuardia if you do
want to fly into their private
tournaments it's very very complicated
so it's much I don't even know if they
have them but it's easier to fly into
New Jersey
the road is about 25 feet from the
tarmac that means if somebody is
tracking elon's jet in real time they
can pull up their car knowing he's about
to land and they can be ready for
something truly awful and they can be in
the building there's no security perhaps
a problem
but when they're publishing the private
information of Elon Musk and then lying
about it there is a very serious
security threat the last thing I want to
mention on this
listening to this Twitter space you know
Brian stelter comes in and congratulates
them on the scoop it's just deplorable
Behavior but the one thing I wanted to
say but there's no point in going in
these room and saying it so I joined a
different room with Nuance bro and a few
other people and I just wanted to point
out a couple weeks ago or about a week
and a half ago
a couple men broke into my house smashed
the window climbed in fortunately I was
not there because we go to Great Lengths
to keep our security uh you know to
maintain security and so for whatever
reason these guys thought I was there we
believe it was targeted so uh uh shots
were fired at them they then fled
if somebody was tracking my real-time
location like on a jet or a car
I could be dead
not just me many other people and so
Elon gets to experience with his family
the other thing I hear is the left now
saying in London filed a police report
on the guy jumping on his car
and it's like their their view of law
enforcement comes from movies there's
two things to say to that first why
would law enforcement help anybody right
now especially someone like Elon who's
associated with the far right or
whatever but more importantly hey shout
out to Luke for you know the back to
Blue sarcasm why would in law
enforcement without doing anything the
other issue that people don't realize is
that the amount of time and energy that
is required to deal with these things in
the legal system it's months it's tens
of thousands of dollars or more and it
pulls you away from your job and there's
nothing you can do about it and the
state could even get involved and
victimize you the victim already so if
someone breaks into your car and attacks
you and you decide to call the police
the police can then say you've got to
give us your records you've got to give
us your phone you've got to give us
these things you have to appear in court
on these dates and you can't say no so a
lot of people who know this and are well
off are probably like we are better off
not filing a report on this one
wasn't there video of the the guy
climbing onto the hood I don't know
about climbing on the hood but there's
video of the guy they said did it
wearing like what looked like black okay
so so they're saying that the video that
that he made up well there has to be
videos because uh I I bet Elon and his
family don't drive anything else but
Tesla's so Teslas usually have cameras
everywhere filming everything yeah uh so
I there has to be some video of it but
you know a cop a lot of the times the
cops show up they're like what do you
want we all want to report like okay guy
jumped on your hood did anyone get hurt
no okay have a good night that's that's
essentially how a lot of cops act like
okay can we generate some revenue for
the state here can we give someone a
ticket no yeah okay I I'm busy kid
that's that's just you know now would
Elon Musk be treated differently I don't
know maybe but uh in many of my personal
instances the cops weren't helpful at
all and many times they just don't give
a damn they just don't care so I don't
know if they would be actively doing
something against someone jumping on a
hood especially when it comes to
stalkers there's a lot of people that
get victimized by stalkers and there's
very little that you could actually do
about it yeah stocking's really
difficult to have evidence for I mean a
lot of times it's like you said someone
was here when they weren't supposed to
be and now they're gone so what should
we do about that like if they come back
let us know oh this guy's standing on
public property he's not doing anything
right or it's like if he comes back that
would be the worst thing right so I'll
let you know after he's already killed
me thanks right you don't you know what
I want to do I'm gonna I'm gonna dig a
moat around our next headquarters
that was the idea that's what I said
from the beginning we gotta have free
Diamond stand we gotta have a big moat
and we gotta have two communities one's
a centralized government one one's an
anarchist one we're gonna see which one
thrives but we gotta have a moat the
centralized one will Thrive but it will
be less comfortable all right uh we'll
see let's let's play out this experiment
I think it might be interesting I think
the centralized side will be very very
fast is able to turn on a dime but
people will be more they're more likely
to be unhappy I think in the anarchist
side people would be chilling but it
will it will grow not as quickly this is
what your memberships are funding I
think it's worth it yeah it doesn't want
to see them it was also interesting to
see Barry White Barry Weiss criticize
musk for Banning these journalists and
he kind of responded what would you
would have done if someone was live
doxing your kids it's an interesting
question because again there's also a
lot of possibilities for these new rules
to be interpreted in many different ways
that could actually stifle journalism
let's not say that there's not a
slippery slope here because there is I
think that still should be addressed in
some kind of way but again a lot of this
is personal a lot of this emotion is
emotional rather than actually being
based on any kind of logic or principles
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
because become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time